to the five directors nominated tonight
you've been singled out for your courage
the courage to stay true to your visions
to inspire passion in your casts and
crews and to dream even though dreams
can easily and unexpectedly turn into
nightmares despite the inherent risks
the outstanding films you've made have
resulted in a combined 37 nominations
including this award here the nominees
for achievement in director Adam McKay
the Big Short Lenny Abrahamson rune Tom
McCarthy spotlight Alejandro G Inarritu
the revenant George Miller Mad Max fury
road and the Oscar goes to Alejandro G
in arson
Oscar and seventh nomination for
multiple nominee tonight Alejandro G
Inarritu he took home three Oscars last
year
the best picture directing and writing
for Birdman
gracias al academia thank you to the
Academy
um I can't believe this is happening I
it's amazing to receive this award
tonight but it's much more beautiful for
me to share it with all the talented and
crazy cast and colleagues and crew
members along the continent that made
this film possible to all and each of
you I thank you from my heart
Leo you are the revenant
thank you for give every soul your soul
your Ark your life Tom Hardy all the
Native American casts all the English
American cast thank you very much for
your trust for your talent
I want to thank Chivo thank you for
bringing the light to this journey and I
want to thank to to our non Milken thank
you for your unconditional support my
producers Mary Perry and Steve bowling
all the people in Fox and New Regency I
very lucky to be here tonight okay but
unfortunately many others haven't had
the same look there is a line in the
film that says glass to his mix ray Sun
they don't listen to you that you see
the color of your skin so what a great
opportunity to our generation to really
liberate ourself from all prejudice and
you know this tribe of thinking and make
sure for once and for ever that the
color of a skin become as irrelevant as
the length of our hair
this is for my father thank you very
much